for years ecuadorans have been
struggling to keep their heads above
water in a troubled economy
eight months ago only four out of ten
people had full employment
now with the pandemic the job market has
collapsed
susana baez takes us on what she calls a
depressing trip
down memory lane this is where she used
to run a modest but successful cafe
with four employees
this was a bustling area of quito where
people gathered on weekends
there were lots of tourists this was my
coffee shop which i had to close
i feel terrible sorrow when i see all of
this all of us
entrepreneurs who put our hopes and
dreams and energy into this in order to
live
now we're struggling just to survive
the few who are still open like ronnie
coronel don't know how much longer they
can hang on
i know loads of people who are
unemployed and who are forced to update
their contracts and work for half
or 80 percent less if they're paid at
all
an astonishing 85 of ecuadorans are now
either unemployed or in precarious jobs
like paolo and fernanda freide
both lost their jobs as journalists and
are trying to survive
selling blood pressure meters soap and
face masks
they have two children
as a family we need roughly 900 for the
house food and pensions
now i can't manage to even make 200. i
don't know what we'll do
ecuador can't access credit because of
its enormous foreign debt
unlike in other latin american countries
the government has continued paying
creditors
leaving almost nothing for emergency aid
for the needy
economist alberto acosta says it's a
structural problem
the paralyzation of the productive
apparatus the pandemic the drop in the
consumption
and the government's recessive economic
policies have created an extremely
dangerous cocktail
which is reflected in the employment
figures
and in a country where massive
demonstrations over the withdrawal of
fuel subsidies
nearly brought down the government last
year
it's not just the economy but the
governability of ecuador
that's now at stake lucia newman
al jazeera